hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play a beauty I saw
yummy mess played this in as soon as I
saw his video I knew I had to play
myself it's inspired
obviously by surgeon simulator 2013 and
the objective is so damn British that I
don't think me as an American can handle
this but I'm gonna try we got to make
tea because apparently that's what the
pansies over in England land drink every
day I don't know alright so there are
various difficulty modes and uh me as an
American has a natural handicap so I'm
going to take it to easy mode okay so I
need to get there's hot water here and
there is I think this kettle oops that
yeah screw you kettle that kettle is out
of order so here's the milk but don't
need any milk it's actual milk tip oh my
pinky's gone wrong what the hell
happened yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
did I need anything uh no I don't think
so okay so I gotta grab a mug ern Oh God
there we go so this guy went through a
horrible accident and amputate got a I
got his hand amputated so we're just
gonna grab we're gonna grab I got it I
got it I got it
hahaha this one's still British
I thought I picked at least British one
in god I can't get away from it okay so
either just flip this right side up
there we go
I am a genius so now haha you can hear
the music celebrating my victory is that
the British national anthem because
Britain is a whole country I know this
yeah there we go
no there we go go there's now right this
is not what Duff Wow now under the
floating arm this is all a lie I'm gonna
not an amputee okay here our hair got it
my fingers normally been that way
ah I was lifting my just gonna wave at
it okay here we go
all right no kidding me god damn this
bull this boy I can't even pick up the
cop photos on easy mode I don't even
drink coffee okay
[Music]
I can't lose it like I did in the last
video I'm gonna oh man I'm gonna I can't
I can't take this stress oh you don't
screw that I'm going for another mug
since they're all down here on the floor
wait hang on
ah stop knocking [ __ ] around I'm tryna
succeed just stop knocking everything
around and we're gonna be fine give me
the damn cup oh wait I'm a robot I don't
feel any pain
oh okay everything's hunky-dory oh I'm
caught on the oh come on the damn
come here crawling around on the floor
trying to get a mug why don't we even
want tea oh wait yes right I don't
okay this one looks [ __ ] like enough
and it's actually upright so let's get
it oh please let me get it I do not get
it okay I just got it ah the music has
officially stopped I have taken so long
to either succeed or fail that the music
actually stopped and I think that's an
insult to me but anyway hmm wow that
with your hand
[Applause]
okay I'm going nuts
Oh alt f4 is super easy mode now you're
not gonna give me that easy I'm now
stuck on the oh god my life is nothing
but pain
I never should've trusted that surgeon
from Nicaragua ah [ __ ] la
[ __ ]
all right I'm resetting the game mostly
because I need to get some music in
there okay so this is a very very very
very very very delicate operation and I
am going to take very very very
seriously let's see hey wait I see
something here
thanks surgeon simulator for the guide
to making a horrible game ah ah come on
oh you son of a oh do I have it I have
it
how do I'm not gonna complain you know
what I'm not gonna complain it's just
iron I don't even know how I have that
but some magical robot powers has
allowed me to hold on to this damn Cup
so I'm going to turn it oh my god I'm
rolling it around Matt it's diving it
it's not even attached by anything
I don't even why I'm afraid to let go I
can't it's like dangling by a string
banner okay
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I mean about I guess not all of us
are cut out to make tea so I'm gonna
take this as a sign that I'm not
supposed to win this game because I'm
not nearly British enough let's see what
happens when I introduced my hand and
click proximity to do things
my hand is officially I'm not doing
anything it's just my hand has
officially broken and 210 billion pieces
man I wish I could I wish I could um get
that Hut out of the way because I just
like to see this for a while because
this is intense
[ __ ] your tea ah I love Brook to get him
[ __ ] your time
[Music]
[Applause]
robots are finally up riding duh my
powers have been unlocked I am too
amazingly strong journeys triggered
something around here I don't even know
how big is this room let's go find out
right doesn't seem to be anything
besides its flag [ __ ] your flag America
declared war on England
we're gonna deliver some freedom
directly to you all right okay okay okay
all right that's enough why is this
kitchen have to refrigerate I don't care
bread Britishness it's too much for me
so I'm done on this game isn't free
though it costs two and a half pounds
however much that is an American I don't
know but anyway so thank you everybody
someone for watching maybe try it for
yourself if this doesn't happen and I
don't know what this is but it's kind of
Awesome if I had a robot arm and started
doing this I'm pretty sure didn't want
to try to kill me okay
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]